what is going on there citizens of the reject
Nation join once again by Roxy Strayer who I
demand you follow her on social media she is
always instagramming and always twittering and
she deserves more followers Roxy how are you I'm
very entertaining I'm very proper and I'm here
for a good time with this descent into madness can
you stand for a second no I gotta stand you gotta
stand here too short there you go yeah that's
better yeah I'm so small we have to adjust it a
little guys what are we watching today Roxanna
said you said the thing to send an event it's
already Madness I was setting you up I appreciate
it wasn't listening properly I was thinking about
the chair thank you for being here I feel like
you've been a wonderful addition to the channel
I'm obsessed with it here I'm so so happy to have
you here each and every time leave a like on this
video leave a like yeah there's some other horror
movies I want Roxy to watch it I feel like she'd
really it joy that I've already seen so my
pair over Tara for a very specific franchise
okay you told me this wasn't a horror movie
you said it was a comedy so I'm really ready
I ruined it dang it ah crap I don't know why I
believed Greg when he told me it was a comedy
I wanted to throw you off this intro is all over
the place Fuller Direction watched along where you
seek over their own copy the scent uh available
for super sexy Rejects at a patreon page cover a
bunch of stuff exclusively over there Rockstar are
you ready to swing into action my swinging monkey
I really am I think it's gonna be playing monkeys
the climbing monkey is going to be swinging her
chair back and forth that I don't do well with
the horror movies sometimes so we'll see how I am
thank you
okay so not in America cause mummy
this does not look fun what an opening
I know I have a friend who does this for a living
really yeah what a terrifying process yeah [Music]
whoa that's actually a pretty neat introduction
for a lead female character a daredevil let's
go back to the car I'll just help the
girls what's going on with them too
bye mummy mama mama
[Laughter]
she comes around she can help
us plan your birthday party this
guy's got death eyes are you okay
you seem a bit distant I'm fine
whoa whoa did was that dead husband or the little
girl okay it's definitely a husband how far back
does the polo holy [__] that was shocking he
thought he seemed distant before yeah now he's
way up there hell of a comedy Greg
it gets funnier I've heard this
that is one of my biggest fears when I'm behind
a truck like me too a ladder or anything yeah
just hate
is this a supernatural movie I don't know whoa
it was just the deprivation of her mind
it's a double meaning it's clever descent yeah
into madness bro depression I think we got it
we're deep you're right we don't have to do this
but I'm not going to be the one to tell Juno she's
a piece of work she came to Scotland last year
yeah and left pretty quickly well I mean [__]
happened I don't make someone leave everything's
gonna be fine it's gonna be great Rebecca said I
can't wait to see you once you got in sure she
loves me and talk to you like that after a year
it's gonna be better yeah who needs your family
I am loving the way this is shot it's
got such a such an atmosphere to it
I'm definitely with you Sarah this is
Holly Juno's Protege bass jumping you
should try it Juno showed me a photo of
when you used to climb together oh no my
bad this classic picture what a unique set
of characters yeah that's really different
love each day to do some employees to see
don't bring the room down lady it's an interesting
way to introduce an ensemble it kind of actually
is reminding me of the thing where I don't know
anybody a lot of their names or backstories
you don't know any of these actors right
Jesus that's so scary
laughs
not again holy [__] is the only scare
for like every 10 minutes whoa you never
know Paul's just gonna drive through her in any
second that was really normally when you enter a
nightmare sequence it's really apparent yeah
they did a great job at misleading you there
the score is awesome too yeah it's really
capturing this dread intensity give me five
minutes five minutes I love how she did a
warm-up run when they're already gonna do a
crazy adventure today yeah but there's always
that one person on a trip that's like that
fascinating transition yeah that's
what you call it a thing Holly
I hate that person on a trip right ladies hey give
me a smile oh my God their last photo [Applause]
there's no sausage to be seen yo this shot
is Straight Up The Shining have you seen The
Shining yeah Straight Up The Shining right
here with the water bottles just uh where
the camera's moving I don't know what you're
talking about the water bottle water cups what
I don't know here's Johnny right I
don't remember movies I don't know
what I've seen and I haven't signs
I figured out the same time too
[Music] going the right way I've never
been lost in my life marvelous do you
like Juno right now or you dislike her she's
all right I think they're all fairly likable
yeah early prediction that Juno was born was
sleeping with uh his husband yeah probably
that's what those shots seem to allude
to and just her personality nice parking
I love the cinematography yeah God uh this
lives up to the title of descent so much
it's just becoming this dark blue that's just
overshadowing the frame I love it running late
a great grip on sound design too yeah everything
like every sound punches I want to
buy a BMW now the river about half
of my flat and stick to it rule number
two don't go wandering off you can get
dehydration this orientation this is so clever
they're setting up all the terror to come while
they're painting us with this beautiful nature
scene and everything it's like pride and positive
love it this is it you're having a laugh I'm
an English teacher not [__] Tomb Raider
oh what a gorgeous shot yeah really
good with movies like this it makes
you wonder how did they get some of these
shots especially as we're going into the
cave it's like yeah did they shoot this
in an actual cave on location [Applause]
honestly in order of following my lead okay
let's get a moment shows that she does take
this serious yeah only redeeming moment
for her character you really don't like her
if she didn't sleep with him
then I do and my bad Juno
and that one's for all you men out there
God damn sound design man freaks me out
look how Batman which way there's only one way
out of this chamber and that's down the pipe
it does a good job at capturing The Wonder of a
lot of these elements and then switching
to but here's why it's also terrifying
oh yeah there's a big No-No for me this is
way too terrifying I would not do this it
takes a different breed of person to be
wanting to do this like this is way too
scary to figure I would never do this I
get being intrigued but I I just couldn't
I wonder where they did shoot this it's
wild this reminds me of 47 meters down
I like how a lot of these shots look like
matte paintings like a like an
old school Hollywood movie oh
I will I will kill you do you know say that
I'm really sorry I didn't stay around longer
accident anyway she's crying because she
was sorry I'm feeling a bit out of it it's
probably jet lag or something so I'm just going
to take a look around okay it's been a year I'm
sure she doesn't want to keep talking about it
what's up with her she looks like she's seen a
ghost or something fine and that goes in there
I think what's up with her so what's up with her
girl's gonna go first I don't know that for
sure hence why it's a movie I haven't seen
I found the next Passage I would
be scared if I yelled things would
just start kind of collapsing
like Aladdin rules or something
this is not how I imagined it from reading the
book that's why I don't trust books careful just
find the way through are they finding like a
gateway to Hell what I'm trying to figure out
what's from the book where this is going yeah I
think they're all under different premises right
now like different submissions I'm saying like
you know what I'm getting at yeah I feel like
they're like fighting like but you were actual
hell you think this is gonna be Supernatural
I don't know I have no idea I don't think so I
think they're just gonna get stuck Underground
whoa cool shot really cool yeah
God they're claustrophobia so that
sucks so much are you not good with MRIS
I do them weekly just to prove
I'm not a [__] dress word
she's the one who I said was
gonna die first right I think so
yeah yeah gross
the way they laugh sadists oh no
I can feel it coming in the air
yo she's like legit stuck
Sarah are you still behind me
you should be fine should be fine Greg she's fine
Greg guys it's Sarah I think she might be stuck
ah what in a comfortable position
keep breathing okay hey okay okay what are you so
worried about Sarah look at me okay okay breathe
what are you so worried about Sarah you're
fine are you her therapist listen the worst
thing that could have happened to you has
already happened okay and you're still here
I love this girl yeah I'm gonna move slowly that's
it grab my arm okay I forgot the Rope back okay
oh my goodness okay [Music]
oh my goodness what is happening
if it was anyone else I'd be nervous
but Sarah's not gonna die she's a
protagonist so I could still feel her
emotions you soulless woman Roxy Solas
it's like 47 meters down on cage thing pretty
sure four centimeters down came out after this so
that's how it's supposed to work except I put in
a flight plan for Borum caverns and this isn't
Borum Caverns is it Juno we're in the wrong
[__] cave oh God Caverns was a tourist trap
I don't try and pin this shite on me this is
not caving this is an ego trip come on Rebecca
I didn't know this was gonna happen you don't
have enough oxygen to fight about this where
a name it's a new system I wanted us all to
discover it no one's ever been down here before
you know you couldn't get away fast enough
we all lost something in that crash
she was sleeping with her man
how'd they shoot this I don't
know it's masterfully crafted
though like they really did an excellent job
I think you're right about Juno because it seems
like Juno and Sarah are both grieving in their
own ways yeah for sure I have three camps I need
at least three more where's the other rope bag
where is it we lost it when the cave collapsed
all right whoever does this
is probably a goner because
right about that timer we're gonna lose somebody
we didn't even like draw straws for this job nah
man I just know who the best one is for the job
Jesus such prowess I can't imagine I think
we're I think we're in trouble come on come on
come on Rebecca yeah yell at her to
go quicker oh there's one right there
you okay that is scary you're gonna
try to use it or what oh my God
I don't know about that babe [Music]
what a reveal that others have been here
that is so well done super well done
oh no well done do you think
everybody makes it across us
yeah I'd say so yeah I think you're crazy [Music]
don't look down back keep going
who's on there right now Beth
Beth is a more likely name
it I thought maybe your name or
maybe yours oh no she's gonna be
okay but this is not gonna go well
for her we'll need everything we got
haul it in
oh yeah this Juno girl's
in a lot of pain yeah yeah
she just like really wants to live close to death
laughs
oh no is she gonna notice the
one that was already there too
I mean I might just assume they put it there
they all must be ripped I know right
they all must do American Ninja Warrior
oh she must have [__] her hand rope burn yeah
going on ouch
[Music]
you could like feel that this equipment's at
least 100 years old no one uses stuff like
this anymore besides if anyone had been
down here and made it uh they would have
named it already so we're lucky they
probably died we get an opportunity
I hope one of them has a first aid kit losing the
Rope bag we lost Juno was like that at first first
gets in the way of the risk is something down
here I can't believe they've all made it this far
what Mesopotamia
do one of those purple light things
oh damn but the mountain the cave and there's two
entrances it means there's another way out come on
that's why you do this for that end result and
then you get that high of overcoming it I just
feel like it's not worth it yeah what was that
did you see that yeah is that an animal I just
thought it was water no I'm pretty sure that
was a an actual living thing come on come on
what are they trying to do that one all right
that's the reason to find
Like Oxygen air waves yeah
okay this is gonna be the first dead person
oh yeah
oh whoa whoa whoa
it's not daylight it's what
oh I was right yeah congratulations
oh is she alive oh my God it's gonna be like a
bone sticking out or something gross isn't there
definitely broke her back
[Music]
oh no I kind of don't want to see it
don't move oh there it is there's the boat
can you imagine that Discovery
if you had a problem sticky
is she I'm really upset with
myself that the baby yeah
[Applause]
is that while the bone is protruding
I need to push it back in oh no
oh God
[Music]
there's a hundred percent
something else down here [Music]
yeah it's the shark yeah
what is that Is that real
[Laughter]
it was calling bro look at
me there's nothing there
I think that would that had to have been real
right I don't know I think that was real I saw
a man are you sure yes and it's not the first time
I thought I saw someone before but now I'm sure
you all have to get out of there
I I'm kind of upset with myself
that I was happy when I thought Holly
died first no no you're a sick human
being you're a perverted human being
that was nice of me sorry for smiling
are those bunnies yeah
that looks like Sarah uh Sarah and Juno
are there there's multiple people two
lights yeah yeah we get out of here which
way are you confident it's dead animals
oh what the hell was that whoa
that just came out of nowhere
did it did it take one of them this is
like that movie that came out last year
with Mother downstairs the Airbnb rental
movie with the mother oh yeah yeah yeah
Barbarian that's what that creature
looked like coming out of nowhere
oh my God whoa [Applause]
is that the girl this is I don't know
she did die first yeah she did die first
[Applause]
nice way to go Juno is she getting in slashes
on him she just got one [Applause] girl
is it vampiring nice work
no
oh this is bad bummer bro
why didn't she say any words though
devastated shock or something
no but you don't sneak up on somebody
I don't think that one's Juno's fault
kind of Juno's fall just saying like she was
in attack mode I understand what happened yeah
were you watching yeah
it's got to be some metaphor metaphor in
coming I'm curious how I feel about the goblins
I like it yeah I I do too but because they're
uncovering a creature it does make it less
grounded of a film which is cool but different
than what I was thinking we were doing [Music]
let's go over this cave and there's a
whole new kind of creature down here
what's your predictions on who makes it out alive
anybody I think just our one main girl just Sarah
not Juno I don't think Juno's gonna make
it we need a reveal of what Juno did
that noise is my precious
[Applause] so they're auditory creatures
we can't see some kind of humanoid thingy
I don't know what the hell they are
oh there's an arrow it's an arrow
you saw that yeah it's pointing that way yeah
I feel like that's the way they should Escape
[Music]
even the music becomes like classic monster music
smart smart
Becca God damn it stop yelling you dumb [__]
now it's just about survival these arrows it's
just about survival now oh no Greg oh no oh no
oh no oh no what oh no why are you saying
oh no what's happening it's just not good
I can just tell something's about to happen I
don't know shut up who are you doing all right
you're scaring me I know no you don't
speak they don't no she's getting it
why do some of these creatures who can't see
still have eyeballs my take is that they've
been down here for so long that they lost
their sight so they had to so it adapt it
by making up for having a really hiding sense
of hearing so you think they were humans that's
my guess they're too humanoid [Music] I I wish
I understood what she was even trying to do oh
now again [__] [__] [__]
ah [Laughter] climbing monkey
s fight it
oh nice was that Juno damn Cheetos Rising
you want Juno in your corner for this stuff
oh totally thousand percent yeah they're
totally blind and judging from what we've
seen I'd say they use sound to hunt with
like a bat and bat I found those more kicks
yeah because you're a screwinger man what if
they don't really say anything I'm positive a
woman knows this is what happened let me
ask you this if she was with her man but
gets her out of here alive is the even Steven
no okay this is all Juno's fault it's happening
what no way you're surviving
she's gonna tell her Juno did it right oh damn
how is she still alive
she's noticing the necklace yeah yeah Juno do this
love each day that's what her
husband used to say remember
at the beginning of the movie she said
that I know yeah because she was right
please kill her come on yeah but it's
hard to do don't ask me but it is hard
killer oh that would be hard
hard to do if I had like a blade
okay
how did an action scene go down
so who did just who was just there
I actually have no idea what just took place oh
yeah I don't know what happened it was too dark
[Music]
oh cool what I think it's the cover that we're
gonna see oh yeah it is red oh yeah is that how
they get out to the world is the exit that
way and you see the cover is this what the
oh
you must survive to confront
Judo [Music] [Applause]
reach it reach it reach it reach her reach it
every step step [Music]
puncture oh it's definitely she's that's
blood that is a that is a big pile of blood
oh look how smart she is oh my God that's crazy
but what does that think it is on
where's the video camera
to prove to the world boom
you don't think the video camera matters
it's the most important thing the whole thing
they're vibing if you don't get this on tick tock
you must survive to confront Juno
why would you yell they're right
there they were right there [Music]
the Two Sisters the big ones Gotta Die no the one
who's like just completely
petrified the entire time
[Applause] nope nope she she don't give a [__]
back please baby listen to me consequences
foreign they're gonna have to climb
across her body to get across [Applause]
what just happened uh oh she's jumped
just give her a titty twister no
craft an item out of him [Laughter]
we don't have that much time
left in the movie Greg what's
gonna happen here I don't know I
wonder if Sarah's gonna kill Juno
maybe she just doesn't save her or maybe
they both get out alive and become lovers
saved her
[Applause]
what about Beth make it you saw a day
[Laughter]
come on maybe quiet honey
oh no
oh [__] I can't even hey
holy crap [Music]
oh the amount of infectious
diseases they would all have
this is it
we know what you did why
would you wear it handicapper
[Music]
to get out no nope nope they could just use her
how many are there so many [Music]
is there daylight that's gotta be
actual daylight but then why with bones
uh
is this the cover
massive spoiler of a cover
the Ascension
don't pull her back down get out get out
she have the keys to the car for her is one
of the creatures in there just camped out
that would really suck if there's something in the
back suit she gonna get like charged
with murder of all of her friends
[Music]
don't pull over keep going keep
going don't get out of the car
now this movie it would suck if she died I
would be I don't think she's going to but
I want to see like what what are we on her for
there's something else that has to happen then
it's a truck you found it
Fair surprises took her that long oh
weird ending moment there Wicked
Wicked I don't know any of these people do you
look they're called Crawlers oh good name Craig
Conway a scar they named that crawler scar sweet
just like after Lion King their favorite movie
well Roxy what did you think so good I mean
they just did an excellent job with that
because okay the the big reveal obviously is
that this is a monster movie which I feel like
you might have gotten more sensitive than
I had going into this because you had seen
that cover with her covered in blood so maybe
were you thinking I mean no when they arrived
they had the the thingy they had the dead
animals and stuff so it just seemed like
they were hinting that there'd be something
I was thinking something as in like Rams
like a real live creature down there oh you
thought they're you thought there would be like a
more realistic animal because we saw the painting
on the wall with the the reason that's why I said
ran it was like yeah okay so I was thinking it
was more like maybe a mountain lion kind of thing
or some I don't know what creature but Panda
yeah something crazy yeah under there I wasn't
thinking it was gonna be a humanoid of sorts right
um but that was a interesting choice and then like
once I could kind of wrap my head around the
choice and really embrace it and then there
were so many of them it was a whole different
Society down there I was like this is dope
yeah I thought that was what made it clever was
because they they were kind of like planting
Little Seeds throughout like they had the hand
on the wall at the beginning yeah that everyone
seemed to ignore I'm sure it's nothing it's just
fresh blood right here on the wall and there's
something just about its mood and tone that seemed
to hint at it have you seen the Netflix movie the
ritual no this is the most that it reminded me out
of all the movies we kept listing this is the one
I thought of the most but I when did this come out
let's look that up yeah that's very serious when
you watch a movie with Roxy it becomes a whole
Google session is what this is why is it what
do you mean you're always like what's the 2007
it's 2007. well why is it listing Rosaria Dawson
um oh that is the movie Descent you're right
okay that is the wrong movie okay [Laughter]
okay something's awesome that's why where's
The Descent how come it's not popping up here
maybe try IMDb it's the international movie
database that's what it is something happens
when you are like boxing unless they've got the
title on the whole time 2005. wow 2005 yeah okay
um something else you want to look up no there's
just this is much earlier than a lot of the movies
that borrow from it clearly and it's still yeah
a lot of movies borrow from it it still feels
it feels like it still could have come out like
this year yeah yeah well it was interesting the
lack of technology in this made me wonder about
the year because we don't really see I don't I
don't remember seeing anybody on their cell phone
or whatever it is no but you wouldn't because it's
cave diving so yeah it does it does feel like a
totally Timeless movie yeah it's really clever
I was so impressed with that the way it just
kept going I haven't quite seen quite seen a
horror movie like this in a while I've seen other
movies that kind of feel a little bit because it's
another horror movie about like grief and then
going on an adventure and overcoming and changing
as you go but I love the parallel journey of the
the cheater and the woman who lost her husband
and kid and how they're both on these like two
grieving Journeys together except we don't like
uh Juno you're not aware I mean she's not making
it um public information for people I bet some
people watch this movie and don't even interpret
it that way well that is what's happening right
that's why Juno's always like we got a little
fear and I gotta like make up with Sarah and I
gotta do it you know no I'm saying don't even
interpret like who knows what her relationship
with the husband was like you know we have no idea
was she in love with him was she sleeping with him
oh um I mean she was clearly in love with him
yeah because that's but she couldn't it was it
the guilt that was you know I think there could
have been so many different versions of it was
it a full-blown affair with an infatuation was
it both side it was it one-sided we don't know
and they don't focus on it because it's not fully
the points when when you have wronged somebody so
deeply there's no time you never able to make
it right because of what happens and you're
also never able to come clean about it this is
what happens to you that's what I mean that's
why that's why I like Juno's the character of
Juno even though yeah like awful human being
like but I like the character of of her because
it makes sense why she would be acting out in
such a different way because she can't talk to
anyone right a therapist would have been good
but outside of a therapist she she can't confide
in any of her friends and then she's trying to
make amends with someone but she can't confide she
can't be like well I loved him too yeah and they
never even used they never even bring it to words
right it's kind of crazy it's clever yeah very
really really good really really solid I think
that this movie it took every inch that it could
like for being what it was which is a movie that
has no A-list celebrities or b-list celeb people
that you've ever heard of and it's almost all
takes place in a cave it gave us everything
perfectly yeah the user environment well
it was like wet icky harsh uncomfortable
the sounds are like they they know how to thrust
in the perspective and um I just love a good title
so I kept bringing it up because it is it is such
a great title for this uh because it's it it plays
on every ass it's it commits to it so much to
the T on every aspect of the psychology and
the physicality of everything and then how it
leads ultimately to her Ascension I think that
is so great so yeah I was really impressed
with the title and the way it was shot was
so excellent because they know how to thrust you
into everyone's povs and we were kind of comparing
it to the thing in the beginning um which is a
movie I watched yes that is a movie you did watch
of air you up again sometime in like
you know 2027 so it's not that far away
um yeah but I like the Dynamics here more yeah
I did too we got to know a little bit more about
the characters here and and like you said the
Dynamics knowing like the sisters versus Protege
versus Frenemies or whatever it was I I really
did enjoy that I thought that they did a great
job with this Ensemble not diving too much into
their backstories but enough that when somebody
died I was like that's a bummer yeah oh except
for when I was excited about being right about
the first day sure sure you had a great time yeah
because I was able to predict some things I mean
I I pretty early on clocked I I think that I
was like oh is it that girl's family and then
it wasn't her family and I was like oh the way
they shot it clearly there's something here and
then it was pretty soon that I realized what was
going on between them but it didn't take away from
the movie at all it was like okay this isn't about
that this is a survival movie I'm curious looking
at this there's a The Descent Part Two I'm sure
it's a straight to DVD monstrosity because or
no I don't know actually that's my dad okay
let's find out 2009 let's look up if it was
was the scent I'm just going to
Google it was the different director
oh that makes me less confident yeah was
The Descent part two theatrical release
let's see it seems like in the UK it was but
not in cinemas it was uh not it was straight
to DVD and I had a 51 on Rotten Tomatoes so
yeah okay well that's not too bad for a horror
sequel honestly uh that's like well all things
considered that's not bad for uh for a horror
sequel to be I wonder oh so she she revisits
the caves that's interesting oh cool yeah yeah
we saw that same I mean you can't have that same
surprise and and also um the because you said like
it is a survival story and I love it because
the whole time it's just stripping them down
to their their Bare Bones their bare Souls by the
very end of it their most vulnerable and you see
what they succumb to when it comes to survival
and because they do such a great job on capturing
the intensity and the horror when it's just a cave
Expedition movie yeah nothing to do with monsters
totally you know and that is in and of itself is
already scary enough as it is and you're watching
them devolve and so and then by the time you get
to the finale like I actually thought the monsters
help to propel what they were doing with the
characters already and I think that's why I
was able to get on board because it is a little
jarring that kind of fits with the reality of
the situation because you wouldn't see that coming
in real life so I think in some aspects it I like
how it kind of comes semi-left field like there's
some there's some minor hints that there's another
creature down here right that's why I I didn't
it's not like I didn't think anything was down
there I knew something was down there but if
you're like me watching this and you feel like
it's a very grounded thing I just thought it was
going to be an animal of some kind yeah I I'm with
you though that when it does kind of come out of
left field it doesn't feel like what were they
doing with that that was a weird Choice it just
feels like oh okay I see I see why you guys did
that makes perfect sense I the way that it was
shot 99 of the time really worked for me the one
percent where I didn't know what was happening
sometimes I do wonder if that was a financial
thing where sometimes they just didn't have it
enough fun to show me what was going on there's
that one moment where after Sarah has said goodbye
to the girl with the necklace who's dying and then
all of a sudden there's the oh yeah whatever and
I was like until this moment I don't know whether
they heard something or that was a different scene
that we cut to or what so it was just a cut there
was maybe two or three of those times where I was
truly unclear about what happened yeah it doesn't
make me not understand the whole movie but there
was a couple times where I was like if you could
have just been a little more uh coherent with that
then that would have been cooler in those moments
right true true because I love how obscured
everything was and I love how um unsettling and
disorienting everything was that's true that's
kind of the point but then at times I was like
[Music]
between the two of us four sets of eyes where
are they show them uh yeah but it was definitely
the disorienting part that you said though it's
supposed to be disorienting so that's why the the
editing really does work for me most of the time
it was just those few nitpicky moments where I was
like huh I don't know what I don't know how we did
that all right that's fine this is one of those
movies I would be curious to see the making of on
because these actors all got in the ugliness of it
all like this looks like a really uncomfortable
thing to fill it bums me out that this was came
out in 2007 and I still don't know any of these
actresses because they were really good yeah they
were phenomenal that's the one problem with horror
is a lot of the time you Horrors that one category
where you don't need a celebrity at the same time
it doesn't really make stars yeah yeah but also
the fact that I know that's okay that's not for
everyone who's gonna clarify some people become
actually famous from horror movies I know but it's
UK horror too so who knows maybe they're very big
in the UK and we just don't know them but the girl
who played Sarah and the girl who played Hulu who
played the app Hulu now streaming because I do
know I got her the whole time I can remember her
name two seconds later I forgot those two girls
are like to me they were such stars and Sarah
is kind of like a low-key incredible final girl
that's what's neat is the fact that I was thinking
that too because it's a whole the whole cast is
women yeah that you might not immediately think
final girl because normally you associate that
one like there's men mixed into the group yeah
um but yeah she is straight up that's what she is
the Final Girl of all the girls she's the final
girl so I this is uh a weird thing but I was
do you know I was a girl scout for 13 years oh
were you okay so until I was 18 which is how old
you're allowed to be when you're a girl scout so
did you petition that did you fight were you like
no they don't want to keep going for another five
no but I would have kept going I love Girl Scouts
so I'm kind of like a a wee bit of a nature not
with some things like I love to Camp I love the
outdoors um and my dad also used to rock climb and
I love um no joke I did love rock climbing not to
this extent and I'm not like a excellent I'm not
a cave Diver by any means but I was kind of in
communities that like to do this kind of thing
and this reminded me of the conversations in the
cabins in the woods and whatnot it reminded me uh
I felt like this was a female writer which I don't
think it actually was which means they did a great
job because remind me of the conversations
that you have and it didn't feel like what
do women talk about when they're doing outdoorsy
things it felt like really what people are talking
about and and how they're conversing and that's
why I love how they didn't make that huge deal
about like you were cheating on me my husband you
whatever like this was very realistic to me a lot
of times when we see men write these things it
does get very Petty and catty as opposed to this
which felt really realistic and grounded even
though we've got goblins that is true I think
Neil Marshall I think the saint I think he wrote
it too I think gotta know Roxy that's why I make
you Google Greg has to Google this to find out
um I think he wrote and directed it too yeah
um yeah that's impressive really good he did a
really really good job with the dialogue in this
it was just that one line that both you and I were
like maybe we could ask for help no come on you
know yeah you know yeah you know you're not asking
that thing totally yeah maybe he knows a way out
okay but yes I I just kudos to him to for
understanding how to write these characters
that is a great point because I didn't quite
know the the kind of people I was liking it to
I once did Tough Mudder and uh you did yeah I was
a nightmare I threw up nine times I hated it but
I want to do it again but you you did it yeah
I survived I did not know exactly what it was
that's amazing and uh it was a I heard to say I
do not prepare for it but I did the whole thing
and it was really hard that's crazy and and
I got to do it with it was one of those like
influencerable it was like the first influencer
thing I've ever done it's such an influence it
was such an influence yeah but this was this was
when Studios started working with influencers
so they're like let me hire you for something
which is we're gonna like film you do some
activity needless to say I was not mentally
prepared or physically at all for what Tough
Mudder was but they put stupid YouTube talking
about movie trailers guy with American Ninja
Warriors and people who had actually done Tough
Mudder before and there were these women there's
like one woman who was part of our group who had
done like a 19-hour tough mudder before I'm like
that is gnarly and then so yeah seeing like and
I met quite a few of them oh these conversations
kind of reminded you yeah yeah I was like oh yeah
these like Thrill Seekers athletes um who like
love to get in the muck and really do these kind
of crazy things so yeah while it wasn't like you
know cave diving but you those athletic Thrill
Seekers uh yeah it reminded me of that so there
was this authenticity that you could latch on to
I wonder if there was like a lot of improv allowed
to yeah possibly it did feel it did feel that
way just in some of their responses to each other
um I loved it I I loved it a lot that that's
gonna stick with me yeah it was really really
solid perfect length to the score was awesome oh
yeah the score yeah just some really smart choices
I think we've broke it down I think we've got
everything we need out of them we took the Descent
to the film yeah I remember when you started
laughing at me because it's like a [__] like the
70th time yeah so the thing about it yeah couldn't
get over it it's a really really good title it's
too good if I'm with you I'm definitely with you
it's not you weren't wrong any of the times it was
just cracking me up how often you were thinking
about it it's normally such a pretentious thing
to say like the title itself can somebody can be
so pretentious and heroes like oh they're doing
it they're they're so committed to it that I was
like there is no there's no other title that would
that would be perfectly encapsulated do you have a
favorite movie title uh you'll have to think about
for next time A lot of times it's comedies that
I think are the best ones oh really yeah I think
if you can nail it like I think the 40 year old
virgin is a perfect title yeah it's really good
it's too good of a title it tells you exactly
what the movie's about yeah really song Wedding
Crashers uh I think is it crazy do you like nail
on the head like yeah oh if you can get that I
know some people like a little bit more if they're
like what is the deeper meaning well that's the
design yeah well but it's both it's both they're
literally descending tell me about them tell
me about the title okay it works with somebody
that's what makes it a perfect title it must be
one of my favorite titles yeah because it doesn't
exactly tell you what it's not like The Descent to
a cave you know but it still is uh it's a pretty
perfect title I truly do good job Neil do you have
a favorite title no I think as you said that I
was thinking like is this the greatest [Laughter]
could be yeah might be just might be I'm a
great when movie fights was around that would
have been a great question I'm sure he did it at
some point what is the best that was the first
thing I ever saw on TV fights your hosting was I
awesome you were awesome leave it in the comments
what's the best title for any movie ever yeah
do it is descent too worth watching ladies and
gentlemen thank you so much for being here Roxy
thank you again for being here and killing it
nailing it way to go you nailed it it was great
first thing he ever did here was a horror movie
so it's great to bring you back here for more
oh no Greg oh no oh no oh no no no oh oh yeah
what
that's what I thought was happening this
morning all righty well thank you guys so
much for being here and uh we'll see
you all soon peace out reject Nation
foreign